Zimbabwe's Matabeleland people are dying
of hunger margaret maganda and her five
grandchildren are picking what will be
their first and last meal of the day for
the pumpkin leaves weakened by months of
this diet
maganda worries the worst is yet to come
there is no food anymore and we are so
hungry that I am losing their strength
to go on
sometimes I wish the ground underneath
could open up into an [ __ ] the United
Nations says southern Africa is
experiencing the worst drought in a
century forty five million people across
14 countries are in need of urgent
assistance while food distribution is
taking place in some areas maganda has
not received any help a three hour drive
way there is food at the market but at a
price
maganda and most cannot afford the ten
dollars a kilo for me or the five dollar
pack of rice cashing in from the
desperation our traders looking to make
a profit so prices are going up for
everyone and so I want to get the best
price possible we are all suffering here
we are all trying to make ends meet
Zimbabwe needs more rainfall for food to
grow in November traditional healers
invoked the nee ami-nee ami spirits of
the mighty Zambezi River to release the
rains but they have yet to come and so
the world's largest waterfall that
separates in Bob way from Zambia doesn't
quite look the same with tourists asking
where has the water gone this isn't just
a tourist attraction it's the lifeline
for millions of people beyond Zimbabwe
is border because the water is used but
with for food and power but look at it
now
gone is the thunderous sound of falling
water left below our hungry animals
dying of thirst after traveling for
hundreds of kilometers in search of
water hippopotamus experiences the slow
painful death from hunger 200 elephants
have died since this summer there could
be more with endangered species
especially vulnerable those alive both
animals and humans are left to graze on
whatever they can and so dulled by
hunger Margaret matanda and her
grandchildren share their meal today a
treat
a portion of maize tomorrow though is
uncertain nicolas honk al-jazeera
Matabeleland Zimbabwe